turn the lights on I want you to see me
this is what I look like
[Music]
que Bonita don't you come to work with
us ineffective what if we don't help
your sister who else is going wait we're
not going to college
ana has an appetite for life are you
gonna be working here full-time just
until I find a better job huh me too I'm
just working here until I win the
lottery before love nice learn summer is
success can write for ideas a man wants
a virgin you're so old-fashioned the
woman has thoughts the mind of her own
I thought but not everyone appreciates
where it's taking her I know he's going
to go to college but not now we are a
family and we inventor state that this
is a sweatshop I'm grateful for what I
my has taught me and I'm proud of what I
do go son Jimmy this year mom understand
you you'll never fit into them is the
size 7 feels like she hates me she
thinks I'm fat and I'm ugly or you're
not fat beautiful from you're imagining
thing I can or cannot babysit though my
lord you would say that wouldn't you
I'm not your baby anymore what is wrong
with us
here is it girls nowadays DT knows it's
so hot in here
you should lose weight this is who we
are mama you wanna see cellulite here we
go mama excuse me ladies the one stretch
marks it's Bella Lane Oh No how
beautiful we are
you could be beautiful stop it
you're overweight kill so why should I
listen here real women have curves
[Music]
[Music]
there's a que siempre dicen que jacket
like okay Latino porque Java which in
today's in Latino
yeah pesar de eso las casas no cambian
mucho SEK holy was in proceed oh come on
lugar de una melancholy infantil para
todos nosotros podemos creado viendo
particulars sobre su dada he conflict
those you know hiddenly han of peru join
us through memoria policing propias
whatever - yeah
she never bloody ever seen Latinos legal
small definitive mr. na no H no because
we want that point of view we want the
Latino point of view in the usage of
this art form this art form is way too
important this art form is the strongest
art form ever created in the history of
humankind conventional película in the
culture película well here yeah making
Europeans in Chilango so onion Chilango
yo girl came in my lab Milan Milan
English from a so trabajando lo lo
Masako Toa Mescon
expressions chill Angus economist
entonces a Unipart que esta hito del
tiempo siempre quiero hablar de mi Pais
no quiero lardo treecko's que siempre
que quiero cantar algún mexico que vea
siempre a lo que digo or avoid hablar de
esta parte de mexico de este lugar oh de
este aspecto de mi propia cultura en
cualquier película film ah dono film ah
de empezar see yo reckon ousia mi Pais
rasa ver las películas a my mission Rico
no ser el rastro de mi país de Ciudad de
mis necesidades de missed a serosa da
missin ellos no se miss Keynesian
approach offe West Oh mija Connie see me
por todos los contactos pero me nación
SLE Spanish in la lengua española okay
in a spaniel ladies in Castilian oh poor
problemas en machine Nellie's mo Perla
banjo really low-skilled habla most
distal o el Atlantico le dijimos Spanish
but I'm a filmmaker that wants to talk
about the human can do
in a universal way I do films about
Latinos and history of your village you
tell the story of the world I tried to
find the common denominator that
connects us to everybody and some of
that is an understanding of the history
similar is understanding of human nature
yeah me me gusta el poder participar no
solamente la converses name is e no
también la cabeza del mundo voce
Mexico's parte del mundo y creo que es
AI Mona tenemos a converse artery por
que todos los effect nos tamos a is lado
y somos un paisa hey no me yo somos una
Isla de conocer otra school to de Zoet
rose lugar es el sin s import notice emo
pero que hay un tipo de de cine OD odin
lo que quieres decir que a veces SI
tiene que ser muy particular meant a H
on Latino America yo / save Eko mundo
mucho Mozilla Dante yo Modelo you
Janeiro saben vamos forma de amar nadie
ghost RDK dare do li are disfavored ad
dare gracias a diós yo somos diferente
good afternoon my name is rainy Hebrew
camp I'm the managing director of
preservation and foundation programs for
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences thank you all for being here
today I just want to say I think we all
pick up well maybe you don't pick up a
newspaper anymore maybe you pick up a
newspaper or maybe you look at your
phone I don't know
or maybe you watch television or your
computer but we all read the news and
think where are all the smart people
they're all here today so thank you for
being with us this is the beginning of
the academies portion of the citywide
region-wide actually celebration that
has been sponsored and coordinated by
the Getty called Pacific Standard Time
Latin America Los Angeles or PST la la
for those of us who are really cool and
hip and so we're very happy to begin it
with something that is specifically
designed to be long-lasting beyond what
happens within these four walls this
afternoon we will be discussing a book
that the Academy has published we will
be meeting the authors of the various
chapters of this book and better best
yet you all get to take a copy home for
free okay
the book of Court yes nothing like a
free book especially one that is on an
interesting topic that we're all anxious
to read from the minds of people who
know something about that in great
detail so thank you for being here thank
you to the Getty for not only inspiring
this wonderful citywide like the region
wide celebration but thank you to the
Getty for including film in the word art
celebration we're one of three film
organizations that are an integral part
of more than 70 that are participating
and the Academy of Motion Picture Arts
and Sciences couldn't be more happy to
film especially in a celebration of Los
Angeles art be a major part of this
festival it's so easy to you know think
of fine art and to leave out some of the
popular arts and/or things that are
really fine art maybe once in a while
that don't get recognized that way so
thank you thank you thank you to the
Getty and thank you all for being here
this afternoon
we also want to thank Bank of America
for being a primary sponsor of this
event the thing that's great for me
is that those of you who know anything
about Hollywood history know that the
Bank of America has always been a
founder of film productions and
financing of film so what could be
better than to have Bank of America
prove their continuing interest in the
arts and film as well so thank you to
Bank of America you were each got a
little booklet here most importantly it
tells you about what our upcoming
screenings will be this is not the
greatest lecture hall in the world
because it's a little big and barn like
right now but it is the best place you
can possibly see a motion picture in the
world this is a great screen we have a
great projection system it can handle
just about anything that you can throw
at us better yet and more in a
diminishing sense the thing that's
really so great is we have great
projectionists it's a lost and dying art
form so especially when you talk about
film projection and being able to do
multiple gauges and handle all the
various things that are necessary to
have a historical retrospective so we're
very happy to have this facility I know
there are people who have looked at the
list of films we've said and said well
I've seen those probably not you
probably not have not seen them all on a
screen like this you probably also have
not
seeing them in quite a while you
probably also have not seen them in the
same context that we live in today that
may be worth reviewing what's going on
here
and I doubt you've seen all of them
really I think there's probably a few
you've missed and so I hope you're not
only come to see some old favorites but
to experience a film that you may not
have seen before or that you only saw on
television or DVD or whatever at home
and I hope you'll spread that word to
especially younger viewers younger
audience audience members that you know
the hope of all of the things we do here
at the Academy is to pass the torch so
to speak to the future generations and
the way to do that is for mothers and
grandmothers and friends to bring people
who have not seen the films or who have
only watched them on their phones or who
only know a little bit about it to
experience something new there is
something about the communal experience
of these films that's very unique to us
and you are now ambassadors for this
program to help us have these screenings
be as influential and is well attended
as the Getty and the Academy hope so
without further ado we're going to get
on with the course of our business I
will say that our opening screening on
Monday night is of zoot suit luis valdez
and edward james olmos and others will
be here it will also be recorded for
broadcast on the frame on KPCC so you
have multiple ways of experiencing that
and joining in the festivities today as
I said we're going to have a discussion
we have another panel tonight called the
Latina experience in Hollywood and it
will be quite a feisty panel I think I'm
very excited about it so hope you'll
come back for that and in the meantime I
want to thank the probably one of the
most
guiding forces of our programs here
today she's going to certain speak today
and serve as a moderator for this panel
she is a documentary filmmaker which is
one way of to identify her she is a very
courageous and passionate woman which is
a another way to identify her she was
born in Mexico but has lived in the
United States so that's yet another way
to identify her but I think the most
important way to identify her she's also
an Academy Award nominee which is
another way to identify her I think the
best way to identify her however is just
somebody that is a great person to sit
down and talk with and have lunch with
and to get to know and who has very
strong opinions has a very strong
example that she sets and most of all is
here today to share that with you please
welcome Laura sporty Oh
Thank You Randi I'm deeply grateful to
the Academy for having invited me to
curate with together with Ellen
Harrington a series of oral histories
with Latin American directors write
producers and screenwriters as well that
contributes to an unprecedented archive
for public access and scholarly inquiry
about Latinos in film this project
involved the participation of nearly 50
members of the Academy Academy's
professional staff across a dozen
departments it was an enormous project
and then what and I would like to begin
by acknowledging their contribution to
this effort in particular I would like
to thank Don Maury as our grants
director who brought the Getty the Getty
specific standard opportunity to the
attention of the Academy and that was
the engine of its success Thank You Don
this is the beginning of a cinematic
resource that truly represents and
mirrors this multicultural nation our
selection of films connects to the
filmmakers who participated in our oral
history project and reflects a time and
period in latin america and los angeles
from 1967 to 2006 along with their oral
histories these artist films reflect a
new direction and production that
engages literature history and open
sexuality for the first time women
filmmakers are represented in
significant numbers and thematically
they are more daring than ever
I appreciate the profundity of the
approach in view of the general absence
of Latino oral history subjects
in the Academy rather than doing for
funk cherry interviews with familiar
stories and remaining on the surface
this project demands digging deeper it's
deeper in the sense that the directors
producers and writers participated in a
long-form oral history of up to five
hours it took the form of a thoughtful
engaged conversation not an
interrogation such an approach
inevitably unearthing is unexpected but
deeply felt subjects the it that
influenced their lives and help them
become who they are for me it was an
enormous pleasure to take what I've
learned over the years in documentary
filmmaking and refine it deepening the
notion of what it is to interview what
it means to ask very personal questions
to look for sincerity to look for
inspiration for dreams for beauty and
storytelling to recount memories and
adapt them to one's work it was equally
gratifying to see the love of
storytelling and construction of
language so I'm hoping that you like me
can relish these enormously compelling
characters and allow yourself to dream
of what will be their next Intermatic
creation excuse me it's hot in the light
the oral histories were the source
material that a group of film scholars
used as inspiration for their essays
that are now collected in the form of a
book which you will have as a gift as
the audience can have the pleasure of
reading the scholars interpretation of
their context the book website the film
restorations and screening series are
the fruit of our combined labor you will
also be able to view their films over
the next three months in a comprehensive
series and hear from any of these
artists
in person during onstage conversations
during their screenings so make sure to
come to the screaming's we're so pleased
that you're here this afternoon to hear
the conversations we have planned
between these authors and I hope that
you will ask your questions to them at
the end of the panel discussion we want
this dialogue to be multi-directional
and include all voices further all the
material used in this project is
available freely to anyone through our
website as for those of you who made the
effort to join us here today each of you
will well you know that you will receive
a book only one book but I've said it
twice so it's not two books this effort
to rectify Latino abscess on the screen
I feel that now is a moment to embrace
this important step and gesture of
commitment on the part of the Academy
and support it well California will soon
have a majority Latino population Latino
Sun in behind this the camera have been
mostly absent since the invention of
cinema really consequently there is a
lot of work to be done I reiterate that
we as Latinos are also part of the
United States as well as Latin America
and we're glad that you're here to see
the work that we've created together
thank you
let me introduce the first panel
moderator Jimmy Mendiola independent
filmmaker and curator director of the
San Antonio Senate Festival in Texas hi
good afternoon and thank you Lotus and
thank you all the people that brought us
out here I'm really appreciative to
participate in the Pacific Standard time
I'm in Texas now I lived in LA so
reading all the exciting things that are
happening here is really great and I'm
glad to be part of it so thanks again as
as lourdes said what we're going to talk
about today is the connection between
Latin American cinema and filmmaking in
the United States which by the nature of
the film industry itself means for the
most part the connection between Latin
American cinema and Los Angeles so we're
gonna begin it begin our conversation
with this panel and there's gonna be a
panel right afterwards so what I'd like
to do is bring up the three essayist
that are part of this initial discussion
first up we have Kerry Kerry Beecham who
wrote in the beginning from Latin
America to Hollywood so Kerry there she
is
[Applause]
and next up Jose Sanchez who wrote the
new Latin American film movement
influences received shared and gained
and then rounding out the panel
Katherine Ben amou who wrote the reverse
angle gone through Como Latin American
filmmakers envision Hollywood so what
we're going to start off with is we're
going to have each of the writers sort
of briefly introduce what their essay is
about and then after that I got a series
of questions we'll start having that
conversation we'll get a bit more in
depth into some of the ideas that
they're exploring so and we kind of
designed it a little bit historically
and historically linear fashion so
Kerry's going to start with talking
about the silent era then we'll get into
the new Latin American cinema movement
with Jose and then a bit more
contemporary Latin American cinema with
Katherine so we can start with Cary
thank you thank you very much and I
really am want to say what an honor it
is to be included with this group what a
joy it's been to work with everyone over
the past few years and really want to
thank the Academy for putting the focus
on this I'm so excited about often in
you know film history and you slice and
dice in ways I kind of roll my eyes
about but this is so important and I'm
so excited about the particularly the
oral histories I mean that's something
that's um gonna be able to be used for
generations to come
and the screenings are gonna be fun the
book is thrilling but those oral
histories Wow well first I have to start
with the premise that it's kind of a
misnomer because Latin American culture
was here for centuries before Hollywood
was so it's not you know it's not one
game to the other and what's interesting
I think too is that filmmaking
originally just to set the tone with a
couple of touchstones quickly filmmaking
initially was very disdained people who
came here were even the fringes of an
already disdained industry filmmaking
was really created by predominantly
women and Jews
people who are not welcome in other
professions it just happened to be this
incredible coming together in history
where these creative souls came to
California and ended up much to their
surprise creating an industry and it
really is true that in 1915 if you were
looking if you were looking for a place
to live you would see signs that said no
actors Jews or dogs
but something happened of everything
happened in 1915 and that was of course
world war one was raging in Europe in
1915 European films were far superior to
those we were creating in America but by
1919 their industry had been ravaged 90%
of all films were made in America of the
entire world's films were made in
America and by 1920 there's over 100
filmmaking companies in Los Angeles
filmmaking has become all of a sudden
not so disdained because it is the major
industry in the town and it's all of a
sudden feeling those hotels and
restaurants and everything else so all
of a sudden people are appreciating it
if still a little bit leery of it what
we also need to remember I think about
particularly in 1920 is there's over
15,000 theaters in America most people
in America have not gone more than 5
miles from where they were born ok all
of a sudden you can go around the corner
put down your dime or your quarter and
the world is revealed to you and that's
all kinds of worlds yes it's Paris it's
London it's New York places where
somebody born and raised in Des Moines
would never see but you're also being
taught stereotypes romanticism in a way
you're seeing women are seeing all of a
sudden these furs and jewels and a life
that they never could have imagined it's
this whole shake up the worldview and as
I say it's available for a quarter
around the corner scared a hell of a lot
of people now back in Los Angeles before
there was central casting the central
casting office ended up opening in
middle to late 20s but before then
even though stereotyping was alive and
well in the casting of these films each
group had a place to go to be cast for
Latinos it was the corner of temple and
diamond we gather there in the morning
and if a particular filmmaker remember
there's a hundred companies working neat
needs Latinos they knew to go to Temple
and diamond where they could pull up the
truck and round them up for Africans
Americans it was at the corner in South
Central for men on horses it was over on
Gower
that's how films for casts that's how
absolutely loosey-goosey much of the
business was and that all changed of
course in 1920s in the late 20s when
sound came in because when town came in
money was required like they hadn't seen
before
Wall Street invested it became a real
business people wanted white men wanted
the jobs the women were massively
reduced in the behind the scenes roles
and it was suddenly a very different
world and they cared a lot we'll talk
later about the way that silent films
were made and the rush to make other
foreign language films and trying again
for the profit but but fear really
permeated Hollywood from the late
twenties on very briefly some of the
Latino actors who who really did thrive
there was Dolores Del Rio and Gilbert
Rowland stretched his career from
silence through television which is
unbelievable
Roman Navarro played Frenchmen Russians
Egyptians it didn't really seem to
matter he could play anything and yet on
the other side there was Lupe Velez who
was ultimately Serio typed in everything
and billed as the Mexican Spitfire so
well we've had many many changes in in
Hollywood over the last hundred years I
would say that one thing hasn't that
hasn't really changed and it's been a
roller coaster and we're still fighting
is is
typing not just of course of Latinos but
of almost everyone thank you I also want
to thank the Academy for doing this this
cultural event which benefits many
people and thank you to the organizers
could be the wonderful job the title my
my is is the new Latin American cinema
movement influences receive shear and
keeping the new Latin American cinema
was discovered in Europe in the 1960s
with the gray of filmmakers award given
to Bolivia score a Zionist for his film
Kamal a Warren in the language of them
are people of the of the N days
expressing that's the way it is and the
best director award given to Brazil's
global Rocha for Antonio das mortes but
at the Cannes Film Festival this
movement was born out of filmmakers
decided to create a new cinema that
would reflect the reality what was
happening in the countries according to
Nancy Carol Hollander quote the new
Latin American cinema movement emerging
the cultural format from the late
sixties to produce feature field from
Latin American audiences that explore
the historical forces responsible for
poverty class antagonism and political
repression end of quote
the work of sang-hee nazar Rocha as well
as college filmmakers like Cuba to
market theory Celaya provoke thought by
not conforming to European or Hollywood
cinema my essay is floor some of the
influences received here and given by
the new Latin American cinema movement
focusing primarily on the period from
the 1960s to the eighties the film's
address have been selected to illustrate
recurring themes in the work abroad at
the Latin American filmmakers and Latino
filmmakers in LA to essential themes
develop aided by the by the new Latin
American cinema movement are reclaiming
culture identity and film as an
expression of historical reality
Jorge's ruffinelli systemin about the
documentary the bottle of Chilean by
Patricia Guzman a relevant quote without
this film perhaps those years who not
exist and occurred in the 1960s Latin
American filmmakers they brought the
available realist cinema that use
experimentation to create authentic
images the new Latin American cinema
movement which includes Brazil cinema
novo was influenced by the cinema India
Satya G's ray as well as film from
Hollywood and the French New Wave
another strong influence was Italian
Neorealism particularly in his
humanistic approach to the development
of characters and stories during the
1960s and and 70s
Cuba provided a harbor connection
between Latin America and Latinos in the
u.s. in 1964 with well destroyed
traveled to Cuba with a group called
student committee to travel to Cuba he
talks about the effect of the trip quote
he created Latin America for me it
opened my eyes to the faulty was really
that I was really a Latin American
Latino you know in that sense really in
a worldwide sense and a good at that
time Latin American filmmakers well they
need to have their own Film Festival
that could provide common ground for
filmmakers from Latin America and other
countries director casues Trevino Sara
when the Cuban response or Latin
American filmmakers Committee which
helped develop the festival my essay
goes on to explore how or kissing
heinous on with well this were making
films alongside the people by allowing
the community to have a voice to the
film's what will make us work in
collaboration with communities their
worlds represented sank eNOS with a
Kamal group on film such as the courage
of the people humble des with the Teatro
campesino
as well as own I am walking and suit
suit in the case of both filmmakers the
work was shared through community
screenings that also serve a function of
building a community some fields
mentioned which address the themes of
reclaim in cultural identity include I'm
Joaquin and Sanjana sees : destination
the quality of the people deals with the
story culture construction as there's a
palette of the Chorio Cortez directed by
Robert yon and hysteria networks a
merciless suit suit suit suit atlases
paltry claiming cultural identity and
historical reconstruction an additional
team consider is how films give voice to
the voiceless using the examples of the
Gordon Ava's Jill Norton thank you
well first I'd like to thank Laura
support the young Ellen Harrington and
Randy handycam for initiating this
project moving at forward it's really
been an honor to work with them and also
with the other SAS and I'm really glad
we have a Tejano here okay my point of
departure was that my understanding from
speaking my first conversation with
Lucas was that this could lead to the
creation of a transparent that he saw
across the border pan Latino American
space for artistic dialogue and
historical reconstruction and I'm really
glad that this is a sustainable project
and that it's thinking about
preservation and education and not just
about a celebration in 2017 and how how
to approach this since we are creating
this frame well to return the gaze
there's been so much scholarship from
North America looking at Latin American
cinema history looking at Hollywood's
portrayal of Latin Americans and Latina
people and even looking at the Chicano
film movement and I really was wondering
if we could sort of incorporate a
different perspective if we start from a
reverse angle and this is not only to
increase attention to the role of
directors screenwriters and performers
in shaping the relationship between
Latin America and Hollywood to give them
a certain kind of agency in in
historical narration following the
example
of Lourdes as wonderful oral histories
but also to uncover experiences and
aspects of these encounters and
Hollywood's influence that have been
overlooked an historical record so I
wanted to I wanted to ask the question
what is the place of Hollywood in the
creative imaginary and career
trajectories a very diverse Latin
American director filmmakers and I think
the oral histories helped to reveal this
I also wanted to cast the net broadly
and consider works including Mexican B
movies that might fall outside of the
Canon and as well as possible links
between independent film practice and
Latin American inroads and Pro Latinas
initiatives in Hollywood and finally and
also the relationship of Brazilians to
this enterprise
if we as you saw in the introduction
there are Brazilians included in the
oral histories Nelson potato two
scientists the great cinema novo
director hector babenco who works across
the thought of the CES line in both
Portuguese and Spanish I wanted to
contemplate finally how the city of Los
Angeles has historically served as a
destination for many film viewers of
Latin American and Joe conics origin as
well as a site for on a visual
production for Latin American filmmakers
so where to start well I wanted to start
right in the middle of the period that
is being considered in 1967 to 2017 to
focus on the 80s the 80s without regret
in a way and this was a very
effervescent decade for latina
filmmaking in Hollywood it was also a
decade where a Latin American filmmakers
that were achieving feature film
production in Latin American national
industries were able to try their hand
at filmmaking here there was a shift
than in Hollywood industrial policy
toward greater inclusiveness of Latinas
representation that was known as the
Hispanic decade and we're sort of
kicking off the series with zoot suit
which also helped to kick off Hispanic
decade there was also a decentering of
Mexican film production in the wake of
the duck crisis accompanied by course
brought of course border productions
located partially in Los Angeles and the
migration of Latin American occurs to
Los Angeles and Sundance to begin
developing new forms of transnational
cinema and so hector babenco was one
bruno bahia too from brazil was another
said he'll allow from i sorry a photo
from mexico has another the 1980s were
also a very difficult and painful time
in Latin America especially in Guatemala
Argentina Chile Brazil that had or were
experiencing the effects of military
dictatorships and those effects also had
an effect on artistic production but it
was also a very hopeful time toward the
end of the decade where there were
proactive attempts to enfranchise
disadvantaged racial and ethnic groups
along with women in national political
processes some countries such as Brazil
rewrote their constitution and finally
the Mexican Constitution at the end of
the decade included indigenous identity
as a possible ethnic identity so how to
make sense of these parallel
developments at what points might they
be found to intersect that was my
question in the 80s a lot was happening
here in Los Angeles
just as the Hispanic decade was
happening we have new waves of Mexican
and Central American migration here and
changes an immigration policy of course
in the middle of the decade and economic
production and this is depicted in film
like born in East LA we see that the
Latino praticed presence is very strong
but at the same time that there's an
urban reboard ring happening and as a
counterpoint to those reporting we have
both the expression of muralists and
there's some wonderful exhibits as part
of PST la about the Los Angeles murals
including one that's being reconstructed
that was next to Roosevelt High School
Boyle Heights as well as performers such
as muddy Eliana Velasco film performers
who was herself a film director from
Mexico or Osaka laureate agua yon was a
wonderful be super heroine known as Lola
laughs Lolita in popular parlance from
Mexico Edward James Olmos so I think is
the face of the Latina 'xs 80s for us
and chief marine who made this sort of
symbolic gesture of well I'm going to
cross the border back into Mexico and
see what happens
in born East LA and finally I'd like to
sort of pay a little tribute to Lupe
Ontiveros she was an incredibly
important actress in the 80s she was in
so many films she was the face of Chi
conics motherhood she was the face of
matriarchal values and power and she was
in so many films and its really was
great to be able to go back to those
performances okay so the next step was
to think about how do we get at
different modes of engagement how do we
get away from the idea of Hollywood is
just a hegemonic power versus Latin
American cinema is an alternative cinema
that is resisting Hollywood how do we
look at the complex engagement that
actually took place between both Latin
American filmmakers and Latina
filmmakers in this time so we begin to
see how the film cultures between Latin
America and Hollywood have actually
become intertwined and they were
intertwined it during this decade even
as strong oppositional movements
developed in areas of struggle that were
ignored by film industries were
beginning to be addressed in the 80s by
a burgeoning video driven
community-based media movement so I
decided to take what I call in my essay
a parallax view on the one hand that
that would include both filmmakers and
their audio
is here on the one hand Cinna philic
memory as cinephiles this is the first
point of contact to Italy between money
of these filmmakers and Hollywood they
would go to the movies and they each
have their favorite movies and you can
find this out if you watch the world
histories and secondly migration and
displacement with Los Angeles as a
destination some filmmakers came early
in their lives some had relatives from
Mexico and went back to visit their
relatives in Mexico and began to create
films with that in mind and somewhat
relatively late in life professionally
so there is the second sort of premises
that I adopted was there's no direct
line necessarily between Sena philia and
film text engagement can take many
different forms nelson padilla de santis
was an apprentice here he learned
filmmaking here
transnational collaboration for example
between Greg Nava and Bethenny vato in
Mexico there were some that relied on
Hollywood for marketing and distribution
such as Ramon Menendez and Stan and
deliver some who thought about counter
appropriation of taking some of the
skills and the techniques and really
creating new messages I would include
Alex Evita
in that and some who worked on parody
the Brazilians are perhaps the kings of
parody in this regard
creative parody which shows their
ambivalence toward the power of
Hollywood but also their admiration for
some of the genre cinema and some who
cite Hollywood who include references to
Hollywood such as Marisol Trujillo and
Cuba Hazaras Gizella in Brazil Luis
ospina in Colombia and some who also
wish to pay homage to commemorate such
as hector babenco okay do I have a
minute sorry okay
lastly
there were two discoveries one was the
importance of the 80s for it was a queer
turn in Latin American cinema before we
had major feature films United States
there were film makers in Mexico who
were making films about gay family about
trans people being social outcasts in
small pueblos and they really sort of
forged the way so that a query discourse
could appear in commercial cinema so I'm
speaking about a total rip scenes work
en el lugar zeal amita's tony are linda
su hijo aha Umberto ARMA CEO and fresh I
talk a lot a bite eaten in Cuba and
secondly I was really surprised myself
seeing kiss of the Spider Woman how much
my opinion of that film changed when I
recontextualize it in this history I
don't have time to talk about that a lot
but it's really an allegorical film that
allows us to think of all forms of
military repression whether it happens
in Argentina or Brazil and how
homophobia is is part of that repression
and the second thing was an appreciation
for the public funding we had in the 80s
and the fact that in fact in doing this
history I had to think back of what we
were doing in New York
creating screening series setting up 16
projectors trying to create a context of
reception in this country and how how we
took for granted that the New York State
Council on the arts might provide
funding for subtitling these movies and
how Ruby rich really helped that process
and how how technologically sensitive
that project was because people didn't
have access to video they didn't have
access yet to digital online media so
I've got a new appreciation
or the real importance of public funding
that we had that was somehow taken away
from us
since then yet to echo that I mean a lot
of the important Chicano films to the
80s were public TV films The Ballad of
Gregorio Cortez some movies you guys are
going to see in this next three months
public money went into two giving
opportunity to us Latino filmmakers and
in creating this you know body of work
that's pretty pretty interesting a
couple of things before I move on I mean
listening to the essays it's a really
big topic and we're not going to cover
it in the time we have here it's very
rich and it's really interesting reading
some of the essays and just reminded of
works that haven't seen in a long time
and you're right recontextualizing them
for now is really important and I think
that's why this discussion is important
because whether we're talking about
oppositional cinema and Latin American
cinema there it suggests that there's
something to oppose and whether these
are these are cinemas that are trying to
create their own new language it's
always in opposition to Hollywood and
that's not necessarily bad III I think
and I think it kind of underlies what
we're talking about but I think it also
affords us in this discussion in the
later in later discussions especially is
is remembering that we're still not
represented on the screen and and and
that's the whole reason we're here and
that's the you know the the the value of
this of this whole endeavor and in
particular I just want to emphasize if
you guys have a chance Monday I just
found out that they're gonna show zoot
suit which is a great film but before it
they're gonna they're gonna screen I am
Joaquin and I am Joaquin which was Luis
Valdez his first film it's completely
restored it's so you know I'm really sad
I'm not going to be here I mean it's
going to show I all that exists now are
like these cheap copies upon copies on
YouTube but if you have a chance of
Monday come see it it's it's it's a
really great film I want to go back to
what you were saying Carrie we had a
discussion earlier and you said a lot of
decisions and these things
artistic otherwise coming down to money
and you mentioned in your piece that
silent pictures weren't dependent on
dialogue and and changing the title
cards was relatively easy and cheap so
you could send a film New Mexico and
Germany the same movie and it was kind
of can you talk about how important the
the foreign market was to silent films
and and about that transition the sound
and the various strategies that Studios
used to sort of fill that gap that that
they suddenly felt you know they had to
to you know send movies in there in
countries own languages thank you that
at one point after like a year because
it took that long films would be sent to
the biggest cities they'd be sent back
then copies were sent to the hinterland
and sent back I mean one of the reasons
when films are now discovered they're
found in Australia is because that was
the last place they were sent and posed
it wasn't we're spending the postage on
sending it back same with Alaska I'm so
it went that that was the distribution
but at one point it was up to 70% of the
studio's profits came from international
distribution which is you know pretty
important and when you all you had to do
was change this little title card it was
a breeze so needless to say sound films
was yet another reason to be scared and
to be honest I think most of them didn't
have the slightest idea what they were
doing many studios tried to make
multiple versions of the same film I
mean for instance MGM's one of their big
hits of 1930 was up the big house they
made it in German they made it in French
they made it in Spanish I think they did
it in five languages with different
actors but often using the same sets or
bringing things back the best I think
example is a universal where Dracula was
remade so we've got the Bela Lugosi film
being made by day with the
budget of about 350,000 dollars and then
the Lapidus of our version being filmed
at night with a budget of $60,000 now
granted they're using the same set but
the 24 hours they're making they're
filming and I love to use the example of
Dracula because many people think that
the Spanish version is the superior film
a little darker a little more risque and
just plain old a lot of fun and it I
think ended up making more money than
the English version did but in their
frantic making of these movies and then
distribution of course is changing too
because you can't just send all films to
all places all of a sudden you've got
this Spanish in places to send in
English I mean in German goes to Germany
and then that's in early 30s that's
already starting to change
Garbo is a huge star but all of a sudden
once Hitler comes to power they don't
want any American films so all these
dynamics are a work and really scaring
them to the point that they find that
the Spanish circuit so all of a sudden
there's a Spanish circuit of theaters of
course showing spanish-speaking films
which they hadn't had before they'd had
neighborhood theaters and of course but
now it's films for Spanish speakers and
instead of providing Hollywood tried for
a few years to provide that about what
ends up happening is Mexico and then
Argentina and Spain become the the
bastions of spanish-speaking filmmaking
and they end up began you know in the
first of 102 ironies they end up sending
those films to America and they're
providing the spanish-speaking circuit
with those films and doing what becomes
a hell of a job I mean really much more
interesting films I think then you would
have necessarily seen if that is stayed
in Hollywood what did the language
having to speak suddenly speak where
there silent
Latin stars Mexican stars that didn't
make the transition because of language
or accents
or accents and it wasn't just Spanish it
was it was everybody I mean you know
that damaged girls were huge silent
stars but their Bronx accents you know
get them out really quickly and and the
sound equipment itself wasn't
necessarily very good so oftentimes
maybe we hear about Jack Gilbert in his
high pitched voice but I think that's
been shown to just be you know the the
sound equipment itself was the problem
so there was a lot of blame going around
a lot of finger-pointing going around
and so the transition was much more
individual with the studios and with the
actors than any you know monolithic
conclusions about that I think I'm going
to switch over to Jose and there's a
really famous quote that lets say hey
Suz Trevino the the US the
mexican-american filmmaker said we're
Chicanos and while he felt was the
northern most expression of Latin
American cinema I'm wondering if you
could kind of expand a little bit about
you talk about the two themes reclaiming
cultural identity and and expressing
historical reality as consistent themes
through through some through these these
various films from Latin America how did
that influence our if it did Chicano sin
law or that that first you know us
Latinos making movies that were looking
to Latin America for inspiration well
reclaiming cultural identity was
important for the Chicanos because he he
he was important to be important to be
seen
to feel basically pirated or the rest of
the of the place of society and one so
that experience for example when when
Trevino goes to to Cuba because Cuba was
a common ground for Latin Americans and
filmmakers in in in LA also to be able
to to see their you know other people
making movies or the cultures and the
things that those people also unlikely
to make I was dealing with they were
similar to the ones that you know
Chicanos in the US we were dealing so
they did anyway basically that health
and realized they were interest them you
know struggling with those things yeah I
was interesting in your piece that I
read and I guess you got it from the
interviews I didn't realize Luis Valdez
had visited Cuban 6664 or actors which
predates I'm Joaquin so I'm just curious
you know there's connection or some kind
of yeah yeah there's gotta be a
connection because you know he he feels
you know it wasn't it was a unique
experience for him you know he felt he
was in Latin American people he felt
that he was a Latino and also he could
you know he could interact with other
people there and I get some some
information about what they were doing
in in Latin America
yeah and Catherine he talked a little
bit about teach marine and and in his
movie and it's kind of surprising that
it played at the Havana National Film
Festival and was accorded yes it won
warrants and they recognize that I mean
they didn't I guess read him as this guy
making pop movies it was sort of I mean
it was a comedy but there was some ideas
behind what he was doing yeah in a way
it was kind of refreshing
but yeah I think this idea of pan latina
that sort of is beginning to circulate
more I mean I we talked about the early
60s and how important that was in terms
of individual directors experience but I
think the discourse of finally Neda is
really beginning to circulate in the 80s
as we have filmmakers like Bregman
going New Mexico making a film about
Guatemalan refugees as we have cheese
muddy and thinking okay and and that's
precisely think you know a key point of
his film is that I can't just be
comfortable I'm from East LA I need to
start thinking about those and my family
and those in the community right who may
not be from East LA and to immerse
myself in that and so he's thinking
about this identity as being a
cross-border kind of identity and
thinking about Lourdes Lourdes is first
film you know this what's that that I
want though is about Nicaraguan refugees
in San Francisco and so we see these
latina filmmakers really initiating this
concern with migration and starting to
think more hemispheric Lee and also
Lourdes initiative to go down to
Argentina and I just went to Buenos
Aires and went to X SMS and I think it's
just amazing a lot about what happened
during that period and I just think it's
amazing that Lewis was able to go there
was 16 millimeter film and to film us
Martha days and to somehow make that
extremely relevant to women and others
who were concerned with human rights
here in the United States at that time
so I think there was a lot of filmmakers
and film curators who were trying to
reframe what Latin American cinema was
so that it could be embraced by us
audience Carrie I know you talked a
little bit about it but can you kind of
expand on that void that was suddenly
existed by the studio is not being able
to produce spanish-language movies and
then the emergence of a Mexican cinema
and and particularly there was a circuit
in the southwest right where they were
showing spanish-language movies to
Mexican American audiences oh absolutely
I mean it that all of a sudden I mean
that became you know the answer to 9
ten questions is follow the money I mean
all of a sudden there was the economic
void they needed those theaters and and
in in Hollywood itself I have quite a
bit on in Los Angeles itself there was a
fairly vibrant for a decade or so of
Spanish theaters and different
impresarios of you know a
spanish-speaking Sid Grauman type who
you know built tried to build large
theaters and and that worked for a while
I think a couple of the things are
really important about in some ways I'm
kind of grateful about Hollywood's
failure to continue to make simply
duplicate copies of their own stories in
different languages even though some of
them are fascinating to watch I mean I
just watched Garbo's German version of
Anna Christie and it said it's darker
it's different it's it's gritty ER she
made films in multiple languages as did
Gilbert rollin for instance
and Ramon Navarro but what I think is
interesting is it all of a sudden when
the film making moves to Mexico and the
other thing we have to remember too that
I haven't seen mentioned is what an
important role Mexico played in that
with the with the Hollywood ten with the
whole we're you know Trumbo and the
whole gang of people move down there and
stay down there for a while and of
course Louie bonell gets I mean Mexico
was like a petri dish for so many
different kinds of filmmakers and was so
important in different ways that
provided that base but the good news
about failing to simply remake their own
their own movies as successful as they
might have been gave to Latin American
particularly in Mexico and Argentina and
Spain chances to create their own
stories and show their own stories and
ship those stories into America and
reverse this trend which was so resisted
by so many of America simply shipping
their stories to the entire world I mean
a lot of people felt very mixed to
to begin with about I mean in lillian
gish said that sound killed the
international language of film it had
been Mary Pickford said sound was like
putting lipstick on the venus de milo
which what are we doing why are we
ruining this gorgeous art form and it
really was becoming a gorgeous art form
in the late 20s with fabulous films you
know the big parade the wind etc just
beautiful films and then when sound came
they almost had to start over so anyway
there's just so many little things that
I think are such interesting subjects
for investigation for later as I said
you know this is a very very brief
amount of time we not gonna be able to
cover all of Latin American cinema III
did though want one to end with one
question perhaps the Catherine about you
talk about you know the points of
intersections you found between Latin
America and u.s. Latino filmmakers and
just curious what were those points and
and more importantly how can they
inspire like a new movement of
filmmaking in exchange and then more and
more importantly help rectify the lack
the absence of Latinos on us
cinema okay well one of the points of
intersection was of course this theme of
migration which I think occurs both in
Latin American cinema and in latina
cinema at that time concerned with human
rights I mean and this is coming out of
the Chicano Movement and the Puerto
Rican movement I think people got it
they got the effort to portray those
struggles in Mexico and and Brazil and
Argentina I think also this idea that
you can create that you can bring your
ideas your culture your ideas of how to
use technology and technique to a sort
of commercial filmmaking situation
ending
aged creatively with those influences
that you got from it and I guess the
next thing is is that just as it really
took you know the sort of Chicanos film
movement in the 60s 70s to create the
Hispanic decade I mean they were there
they were ready for it but they were
ready because they had been very active
in their communities before and so I
don't think we should forget the
importance of that that we need
independent filmmaking that it feeds
major filmmaking in certain ways and
that we need to be open to those
channels of communication and the next
thing is I think I definitely think
hemispherical II don't just think about
I mean I think the local is extremely
important the trans local is very
important and I think with recent events
I think we're becoming more aware of
that and I think this idea of of needing
to travel that if you're filming travel
is good I think that continues to be
true and I think we need to create
different venues located in different
places for that conversation to continue
well let's give our writers a big round
of applause they I I encourage you to
read all the essays in the book you're
gonna get it's amazing stuff you'll
learn lots and it's entertaining and
it's provocative and it's fun so again
thank you guys well work it's gonna
happen now is we're gonna hand it over
to the next panel but before that starts
we're gonna see some clips so again
thank you guys so much
y para Mian seen a Hunico truck seoane
un proceso de pensamiento yo no Kroger
pensamientos to xn toda motion no no I
shall go free Yoli huh no but a Mucha
gente me película son free up again I
música no no no no no veo el supreme en
toi romantic Oh que que tienen algunas
otras película pro bono es otro cosas
pero SI lo que creo que la película son
un proceso de pensamiento donde durante
una tow son dose or ahora media uno
comparte con el expected or no no tanto
you nice toriel sino communi forma en
que se construes en la cosa
unconditional oh no lo piensa
básicamente in messiness he con largo
this in context in Xi'an propia learn a
story apparent are seein honoring me the
other surahs a adaptare is muy difícil m
básicamente por una por una razón que la
novella he say don't you see adaptogen
realmente illa seen a lingua Terra
novella Elin huaca de cine
nosotros no son igual a son an tipo de
s-- y en el n Guaje de la novella lot
ranma's central SL tronco Flores a un
montón de rama's case unless he story o
second areas Enrique's in the trunk oh
yes si named as bein his common herbal
and on the last ranma second areas son
he rises que tienen que fertilizer la
trauma central a well here dispersion as
he Arriba
is a contemplando a key role in the
Cesario in la película una feebly dad in
la película entonces es de primera cosa
a person lenguaje Santi poses men Carina
Maria Rojo lackeyson muchísimo yo
adorable okay yeah bah Okubo person ah
hey en una película dermis EO que se
llama Asteria de mi corazon
combien de Cobo encanta lo que son ISA
película me encanta yeah como extra
stole okay hey Cho pero de película algo
muy muy poderoso Escriva endo van son de
sel initio rollatini lien meant a yo
nunca a head a tener swim again
Su Su for Mizzou sonrisa Sunnah sense on
reason franca Cognos DN totus grande
Otis que tiene su su cosas como mover
dad era muy breaded era de mujer / dad
Iran Oh entonces a few sceeto para a
confirm a scree be ahmo's a Lyon MP
septum our classes dance on Konya yeah
yeah Varla el salón de baile La Colonia
Kato be exist yeah I - ma ma nuestras
classes divinely I grab Abba yola's
Alicante bailando grave a grave a grave
econ me handycam horas y ahora
you're a saint of Ireland and some
Quintin yendo local dance on if you prep
the candle up to 10 by 11 mucho is a
fort unless you're me Amistad Kanye yo
sabía que yo estaba scree be end o essa
película para otro hombre con was coming
here not k HBO I said esta película vas
honest our exam every women have curves
get silly in today's eye into a lady I
mean hombre oh no let's plug Taurus yeah
just measure my on a main thread it
started yeah just enter a star now I
really like stories in Trey HP or loss
product or this emails coherent at me in
to tell me do me I mean a hacer cosas
que nunca HBO hecho por amplify a la
primera película case a film in
widescreen the HBO porque la Ola mucho
el a party swell ego tomorrow a tomar
fotos eCornell cinematographer it to
Julie most relays photos si nos give
invented to sell the who know pursue
stem esta come in siento que ambos wider
screen yeah alright todo is why the
screen tambien may hope on it Hispaniola
mijo no porque in Salman Tito Aaron
English Mahan oppa sister Keri fungus
paniolo
into this list entosis Fraser cosas que
que también fue mucho trabajo determinar
but case really stoner dawned upon
release panel in Kerala Sione alappuzha
Moses Ferran muchas cosas que no eh-eh
volantis 1112 mentor per second burst a
la primera película is true here on
parity at rose and lugar de Cali
okay hello hello good afternoon
everybody
that's I love that my name is Alex
Rivera I'm a filmmaker and occasional
media artist and I'm here to host this
second conversation I want to thank the
Academy and the organizers of Pacific
Standard Time for making this event
possible and for inviting me to be be a
part of it okay
introductions okay we're gonna invite
our panelists on stage are joseline
Defrag also a film scholar and author
who wrote the first book on Chicana and
Chicano film culture carlos gutierrez
co-founder and director of cinema
through peak al new york-based nonprofit
media arts organization that presents
and promotes Latin American cinema
Carlos and Laura Isabel sedna associate
professor in the division of cinema and
Media Studies within the School of
Cinematic Arts at the University of
Southern California thank you all for
joining us ok so just I guess before we
get started I was just going to share a
few just format kind of thoughts so the
panelists that are with us have written
these extraordinary essays that are in
the book that you all be receiving on
your way out
and the the essays were based on
research that they did inside this
archive a new archive that Lord of this
Portillo produced we just saw some clips
from some interviews from that oral
history right so these the researchers
here with me have been looking at that
material and produce these essays that
are in the book and so if you're curious
to learn more about what they're
speaking about it's all in it's all in
that book and because it is in the book
it gives us a little bit of the luxury
to we'll touch on what the essays
explore but we're also going to try to
cover a lot of ground to talk about a
set of concerns and and questions around
Latin American cinema u.s. Latino cinema
and everything in between if there's
anything and so there'll be time for the
four questions from the public after
this conversation so in about 40 minutes
we'll be opening the floor and we'll
also invite the previous group of
writers onto stage with us and so
there'll be a chance for you to ask
questions of this group as well as the
previous group in about 40 minutes and
because we're on a schedule I will be
keeping track of time so I might might
cut you guys off yeah I don't I don't
want to but I'll enjoy it if I have to
anyways just kidding okay so we could
start I suppose with okay all right
well I first want to start out by
thanking well thank you for the
introduction Alex and thanks to a Randy
haverkamp Ellen Harrington and
especially Lou the support to you for
including me in this project as the
title of my essay a cinema of her own
makes evident mean the topic is on the
role of us Latinas and Latin American
women in cinema and this topic grows out
of a long-standing concern of mine with
the exclusion of women of Chicanos in
the Chicano film movement with Latinas
and Latinos in Hollywood nots only on
screen but behind the scenes in creative
roles as cinematographers directors
producers writers and so forth I mean
the exclusion of Latinas and Latinos in
Hollywood as many of you know is
systemic and so I want to commend the
Academy for taking this positive step
right in recognizing the richness and
diversity of Latin American cinema
creating an archive that would be
accessible globally
I mean it is the first it is the first
step because I think as we could
probably talk on this path we'll
probably talk on this panel there is a
dearth of Latinas and Latinos you know
within within the archive recently
there's been a lot of criticism of the
exclusionary practices of Hollywood but
this is not just a problem in this
country I mean but also within the
national film industries in Mexico and
Argentina in Chile in in many other
Latin American countries in Central
America as well the under-representation
for instance of indigenous and
afro-colombian a teacher calls the
visual apartheid in the industry because
I do believe that this has real
implications in the political world
I mean Latinas and Latinos are the most
underrepresented racial group in
Hollywood in a film industry that's
located in Los Angeles where that binos
are half of the population and so what
does this tell us we don't need to go to
the u.s. to the San Diego Tijuana to see
border wall you know there is a studio
border wall right here in LA no
unfortunately I wasn't able to discuss
all of the major latina u.s. latina and
Latin America and women filmmakers in
the essay mostly due to space
limitations I mean this you have 21
countries in Latin America in the US and
I had 15 to 20 pages to talk about them
so my focus of the essay is on the women
who were who were interviewed by Luis
for Theo as part of the Academy's oral
history project and it's not an overview
of us Latinas or Latin America and women
filmmakers because I wanted to write
about their work in some depth you know
because I was
and with the question of whether or not
it makes a difference who is behind the
camera as director as writer as the de
matagi fur or with determining if the
exclusion of women in the film industry
and not just on the screen results in a
different kind of cinema that's a
question that I posed myself in the
essay and so based on the filmmakers
that were interviewed by Laura de sport
video there is evidence to suggest I'm
not a social scientist but I'll just say
from what I saw okay that creating of a
film from a woman's perspective makes a
phenomenal difference in how audiences
see the world in how we interpret
reality the kind of quality of the
stories that we see on screen so what I
do is I structure the essay into two
parts the first part is on women who
helmed films from a gender perspective
whose films reflect the diversity of
women's stories of women's voices of
women's culture of women's issues of
women's experiences and then I the
second part of the essay I reflect on
women in the industry in who working
creative behind-the-scenes roles as
producers and screenwriters but whose
work this not is route really focused on
women's stories so kind of that's
basically the gist of my essay thank you
so much actually might my essay well
first of all but also join my fellow
panelists in thanking the Academy for
this wonderful opportunity my essay
books is a bookend and in that sense
actually um what I what I try to do is
like truly to excite people we're really
in the midst of an amazing Latin
American Renaissance that's been going
on for 20 years now but still really on
a really very underappreciated actually
it's been 20 years this November
since Pisa be rife a so
Pizza beer and cigarettes buy a drink at
Dino and Bruno's Leonato kind of open
Harold at what was called a new origin
teen in cinema that enabled a younger
generation of filmmakers to really kind
of break up with the traditional
narratives of doing more minimalistic
stories and also finding a new ways to
found to to produce their low-budget
films that along with the phenomena of
what what I would call the global alters
the emergence of Amore's perros and its
impact in 2000 city of god in brazil
fernando meirelles as well as e tu mama
tambien you know that queer it kind of a
big momentum that kind of set the
platform for what's been going on since
then what's been quiz is that you know
having working cinema tropical kind of
started around the same time and many of
my colleagues we thought you know maybe
it's going to last three five years
because you know in in in Latin American
cinema there's been a lot of ups and
downs in terms of and Finance your
finances but then we're 20 years later
and it's just incredible just to put
some examples and without taking too
much time you know like even like a
country like not only like where
countries like Mexico Brazil Argentina
which by the way they're all breaking
production records Mexico is made 160
films last year more than ever but also
a countries that didn't have like a
traditional film industry like Costa
Rica in only two years in 2014 and 15
they duplicated all of our films in the
history 20 films and it's not only the
numbers and also the box-office and
locally it's also I think the artistic
freedom in different levels there's been
the the filmmakers are really a descent
at the core they find always really
hybrid models of productions that have
enabled them to really push the envelope
artistically and I think that's a key
element to all of this both in the
mainstream independent fiction
nonfiction experimental another key
element it's also kind of a boundaries
between traditional cinema and the
visual arts I think we're really in a
key moment
and I think Latin America has a lot to
teach to a world because we already you
know we had so a little Maya say um
talks about all of this and and also try
to I mean try to understand what's been
happening because again it's been so
vast and so big and in different levels
of course in Hollywood as well I mean
who would ever imagine that that to
Mexican that a Mexican national and we
had two Mexican nationals winning three
years in a row the Oscar for Best
Director I mean that changes the whole
paradigm of how we were taught cinema
however thought about our cinemas twenty
thirty forty years ago but not but then
again also hollow it is not only the
pinnacle for you know it's not a tenet
to itself many filmmakers have decided
to I mean they never consider even
Hollywood as a as an option for many
filmmakers I would say the majority
they're very happy they find ways to to
work locally but then also this I hope
different transnational cinema going on
in this sense that a lot of Latin
American filmmakers actually not living
in their new places of origin but then
again creating work either back at at
home or in other countries and that also
including the US so kind of in a
nutshell that's why my essay is about
fantastic
so um one of my key interests as a
scholar as a historian of cinema is in
exhibition and distributions kind of the
less sexy side of the equation and my
kind of first scholarly work really
looked at that in the 1920s in Mexico
when American cinema dominated Mexican
movie screens and I came to oh I'm sorry
I really need to thank Ellen for
including me in this project and Randi
for such a beautiful set of programs and
lourdes who is an inspiration always
okay so to return to my thought so what
drew my attention in this project was to
think about so we've heard a lot about
production and who's behind the camera
etc to think about how those films
circulate and one of the most important
circuits that Latin American and Latin X
film travels on is the International
Film Fest Intl and domestic film
festival circuit it's an incredibly
important kind of node in their lives as
films and I think that anyone that's
paying any attention at all to the
International film scene is struck by
the fact that the international film
festivals are incredibly important in
bringing Latin American and Latin X film
to the attention of a broader public I
think some of the films that you talked
about their very first introduction to a
wide public was at an international
festival so it occurred to me that this
was a really critical aspect of the kind
of project and thinking about how these
films circulate and in the essay that I
wrote which like Rosalinda my essay
wanted to be a lot longer it really was
really begging me to make it twice its
length
I began by historicizing the presence of
Latin American cinema in large
international film festivals initially
in Venice and then it can rate in the
30s and the 40s and I think that we know
these kind of touchstones of Latin
American film history where in the 1940s
for example you know
Emilio Indio Fernandez that maybe or
maybe not I know the Academy says he's
not
for that his film Maria Candelaria wins
the Palme d'Or at can in 1946 and Louie
boon well who's living and working in
Mexico in the 1940s and 1950s wins the
Best Director award in 1951 for los
nevados and then continues to receive
recognition for other films that he
makes as well as Brazilian directors etc
and this kind of recognition at these
very high-profile international film
festivals was important although it was
sporadic especially in the 40s and 50s
it was not a consistent thing but
generally I think we can say that Latin
American contributions to programs of
these marquee festivals which is how I
think about them Venice can and Berlin
were overshadowed to a certain degree by
quote-unquote art cinema from Europe and
sometimes Asia but that these really
early experiences of recognition were
really important for setting the stage
for what would happen in the future in
terms of Latin American cinema being
recognized I know we have heard already
from our other panelists about new Latin
American cinema and that kind of
movement in filmmaking also found
welcoming audiences at European film
festivals although I don't think that
that's necessarily the audience that
those directors were trying to speak to
kind of initially but you know black cod
white devil I won't say it in Portuguese
was meant Portuguese is really bad and
be the SEC us both Brazilian films write
about poverty and power social power in
northeastern Brazil both screened in the
official competition and can in 1964 and
both circulated in American independent
film festivals that began to emerge in
the 1960s but even the most ardent film
buffs oh I did a lot I did a really deep
Drive because I'm an historian so I got
really into not just the archival
material produced for this film for this
project but also newspapers and the
trade press etcetera I went to the
Academy library the Margaret Herrick
library and spent a long time there but
it's
clear that there was limited exposure to
Latin American films for certain
audiences as kind of art films and I
think Carrie kind of gestured towards
the spanish-language film circuit in
which popular Latin American films
circulated in his period but in the
1970s and 1980s this kind of weight
distribution of Europe versus Latin
America began to change and that
happened with the emergence of festivals
oriented around the what I'm going to
call it a lot-- Enix experience as a
shorthand Chicano Film Festival's Latino
film festivals in which not only are
they showing the work of us-born latnok
filmmakers but also retrospective of
Latin American cinema new Latin American
cinema etc and I think that those
festivals in particular and this is
something I'm exploring in another essay
that I'm writing served as kind of
points of encounter between Latin
American filmmakers and us born latina
--ks in which people like myself and
were born in East LA right had the
experience I've seen Latin American
Latin American cinema for the first time
right after having been raised on a diet
of George Lucas and Steven Spielberg so
using the oral histories I traced this
history and then I tried to come up with
some kind of analysis of how festivals
functioned for filmmakers and their
films and you know I found that the
festivals really brought films to the
attention of distributors and critics
and there are numerous occasions in the
world histories in which people talk
about the importance of festival
exposure for finding a wider audience
for their work they often in very
practical terms someone was saying
follow the money I think that was also
Carrie but allowed filmmakers to secure
funding to finish a film or to start a
new one and there were numerous examples
as well of that being a really important
mechanism and I think that's grown even
more today
and finally Catherine mentioned Sundance
which grew out of the Sundance Film
Festival but the Institute at Sundance
really
a mechanism for fostering independent
film production not only in the United
States but across the hemisphere because
they created models of workshops and
mentoring that were replicated in other
countries so festivals perform all these
important functions and in the last part
of the S I could have take up what maybe
is the negative side of festivals being
so critical to the circulation of Latin
American and Latin X films and that is
that they also serve as kind of
gatekeepers of film culture right
deciding which films are going to have
the opportunity to be screened sometimes
even which films will ultimately get
made right if they're providing
finishing funds etc and even on a more
theoretical level having a strong hand
in shaping categories like Latin
American cinema so instructing audiences
in what Latin American cinema is right
which may not actually be the totality
of media that's being produced in other
countries and this is you know there are
a lot of reasons for this which we can
talk about and there were several
interviewees who talked about the sort
of limits that festivals put as they saw
it kind of very particular sights of
sorts of films right the limits that
they thought were being put on there
kind of art their creative process and
ultimately the kind of films they wanted
to make wonderful
as I mentioned we're gonna cover a lot
of ground and ultimately we're going to
take a dive kind of into what are the
kind of mechanisms the structures the
supports that have kind of enabled this
this Renaissance a filmic production in
in Latin America and then we'll sort of
try to come to understand a bit of how
that's working why that's happening and
then turn to maybe there's some lessons
learned there that we could bring here
in terms of supporting the development
because really we're starting kind of
from zero of a u.s. Latino cinema so
we'll get there eventually but first I
just wanted to highlight again this
question of the archive that's been
created by Lord of this as part of this
initiative and ask the researchers kind
of in going into this new material these
new oral histories was there anything
that when you were doing your research
that just surprised you anything that
just to kind of because it's a public
archive to maybe entice people to get in
there and explore a bit themselves when
you went in and started to hear these
stories did you was there something that
kind of caught you off guard or that was
that was particularly tasty I think when
Catherine mentioned Lupe Ontiveros I
think that that brought to mind but
reset Cardozo's interview and when she
talked about trying to she got hired for
lifetime to do a film and she at the
screenplay and the screenplay had a male
playing the doctor and so she wanted to
cast a woman and she you know chose Lupe
Ontiveros to it and the exact executives
were like really upset they said no
because not only does the screenplay
call for a man to do it but there's no
Latina doctors you know and she just
kind of pushed back I mean and I was
thinking to myself because it's like
when I grew up and I'm talking about the
50s and the 60s
I remember mexican-american doctors in
South Texas there were women and so I
thought I thought to myself you know
this is the perception that
studio has of Latinas and Latinos so
that that was one part and the second
part I mean I'd let me just say the
second part of Patricia's interview
where she talked about the vetting
process that is so strenuous in order
you know she she became four on seven
times she was one of two people selected
to do a major Hollywood film and so the
vetting process you go through various
kind of interviews and the final
interview of the two people that were
finalists her and you know another guy
you know get interviewed by the
President and in all seven times he
chose the white male director and she
and she and she so there's like all
these doors that are closed you know
it's not that it was surprising it was
just to hear it from her in that
interview that was like really kind of
kind of shocking so when you say why
aren't there any latina directors you
know this is you know one of the answers
for this as well so that kind of hit me
a lot and just one for folks that maybe
you're new to this conversation or just
stepping into it we're using the terms
you know there there's a question of
language to describe these communities
and generally we try to use the term I
suppose Latino to talk about folks that
are kind of born work and struggle here
and Latin America Latin American for
folks that are in you know all the
countries south of the border so there's
just in case people are not in meshed in
this conversation already but um okay so
Carlos anything in the archive that
jumped out at you sure and I have to say
in addition to being a pivotal filmmaker
Lou this she's an amazing interviewer I
mean for you to explore I was gonna say
in terms of kind of the transnational
and that kind of
I was instructing in in in in the front
of squadron's interview you know he says
that actually he has never lived in LA
when he made the little princess he
spent some time here but he never
officially moved moved to LA and there's
a wonderful quote from him is like he
says the noise of a factory doesn't
doesn't let me sleep at night so it's
interesting that someone like Alfonso
Cuaron who lived in New York and I
believe now in London you know has the
impact that he has without having to be
permanently you know in LA well I teach
at USC in the School of Cinematic Arts
so a lot of my students are undergrads
who want to be filmmakers this is their
dream kind of across the board some of
them want to be editors because they're
kind of smart III think I'm like there's
all these other jobs that people have in
the film industry but one of the things
that struck me and I'm excited that
these materials are available for the
public to use is that I want my students
to read about how long people work
before they get their big break the
student film that they make with Becca
here or fellowship here and some money
that you borrow from someone here etc
etc and the kind of process that goes
into that ice in Syme not a filmmaker I
you know I was like oh that's really
interesting that's kind of their very
frank discussion of times when they
thought I'll never be able to finish
this film because I don't have any money
and it's just a project that's sitting
around and I think but I think it's it
was especially exciting for me to
contemplate having my students read
these first-hand accounts of what it's
like because they all think they're
gonna graduate and someone's gonna give
them the director's chair and and it's
kind of a nice dose of reality right so
I really appreciated that in the archive
but the three comments together whether
it's hearing the stories of struggle and
rejection by the studio system or
Alfonso Cuaron's advice you don't need
to live here all right then it's going
to be terribly difficult it's basically
it sounds that now I if I'm ever feeling
too good I guess I'll take a dive into
the too optimistic no it sounds it
sounds it's reality I suppose what
you're gonna get inside this archive is
something real and that's that's
ultimately incredibly valuable and
especially deep deep exploration of
these experiences from this community at
this time you know sounds it's
super-important and I can't wait to take
a look myself I'm so now pivoting a bit
towards towards Latin America and this
question of the this kind of Renaissance
and Carlos I thought the way you
described it was fantastic just from
your your your friends and your
community's point of view of thinking
wow this is a kind of a moment this year
let's let's do something let's create an
organization to give it a push this year
or maybe next year it'll continue and
here we are 20 years later and it's
still going so could you speak just I
mean maybe take a few one or two
countries and speak about the systems
what changed or what's what what pieces
of the puzzle moved to start this film
production Renaissance happening and
sort of maybe if it helps perhaps you
could start with anything in the kind of
public system in terms of governments
what though what they were doing and
then also speak about this sort of
market and anything that changed there
and but and the way we'll do it is maybe
a production distribution and then
analysis of what what what is it
happening and what isn't working so that
that's maybe how oh sure I mean I guess
we also have to contextualize what's
been happening in Latin America the past
15 20 years but likely because I think
this Renison is a product of kind of the
emergence of a big civil society it's
not the government's coming in and
saying oh there's this money now it's a
it's a struggle you know after Matt
Makaha had
most of the countries had a very
difficult time in the 80s and through
the early nineties we saw a different
kind of political emergence in Latin
America and we which kind of reflected
in the political in the in the in the
government's but I think it was you know
it's it's a very interesting period
what's what's been happening of course
now we're going to another change of era
let's see you know where that leads to
but but I think this cinema has been a
reflection of that but but I think what
it skis like the the growth of a civil
society so in that sense filmmakers have
been taking the camera as a way to
really push the envelope to try topics
and try to issues that they were not
explored before
and what has allowed for that is I think
they hybrid model of productions trying
to find monies from different sources
but at the same but the same time
keeping their district freedom so of
course there's some government support
there's a lot of tax breaks very
interesting tax breaks that have allow
companies to invest in in cinema
directly instead of paying taxes that
has a major impact in Mexico and Brazil
for example another key element has been
international co-productions like
countries like Guatemala that doesn't
have a strong support you know the but
the molecule makers have been able to
get funds from other parts of it and
where those tax breaks new initiatives
that kind of timed out with this
renaissance or had they been
long-standing you know actually the New
York antennas cinema it's tied to a very
innovative film law in 1994 and actually
afterwards a lot of countries have
followed through and they have added new
things Brazil Mexico Colombia I think
probably Colombia has one of the most
interesting models because they really
learn from the other countries so it's a
very dynamic that allows for different
types of production and again different
and diversity I think is also important
here and I try to avoid the word try to
avoid talking about Latin American
cinema because it's very reductionist
even with countries even within
countries I think we need to talk about
Mexican cinemas in plural or Argentine
cinema Brazilian cinemas because you
can't there's such a diversity of
product
that Juke that one size doesn't fit at
all
that's I think also very important and
the third part and I finish with this
I remember Alex we were in a panel once
and you said we you know we we need to
we need to claim the right of failure
and I think and I think that's what's
happened in in Latin America that a
filmmaker that a filmmaker that their
films doesn't get screen or shown and
that's a case I mean distribution and
exhibition it's a worldwide problem but
that doesn't that doesn't curse you and
banishes a queer contour the rest of
your life so we have a lot of 3d euro
filmmakers making fifty six seven eight
films there's a whole continue process
that doesn't that separate it from
production from distribution and
exhibition which i think is also key
separating production from distribution
exhibition to we solve the issue of this
revision exhibition but so in terms of
like the essence of these some change
systemic changes that occurred in in a
few latin-american countries that enable
this new tax incentives changes in civil
society in terms of new investment
capital coming to the table those the
kind of bullet points of what what is
the underpinning let's say just in the
case of Mexico what did what enabled
this new kind of Golden Age or platinum
age perhaps to emerge would those be
some of the bullet points or yeah
totally and a combination of diversity
of funds and and again artistic freedom
that happens in it both in the
mainstream because also I mean I think
cinema I personally think cinema is just
there's is it's in three obsolete like
Karim is like that falls division
between arts film as artists calmer and
commerce is completely outdated in and
in that sense I think a lot of films in
a mainstream in Argentina in Mexico a
very potent a very political at the same
time but because they're made in that's
former production they they're not
validated outside you know so what we
have I think it's an impressive body of
work
a really vast generation of filmmakers
and we're just waiting to make sense
because still very even though Latin
America again has become an epicenter of
international cinema still so on the
represented evil festival circuit and
we're still kind of trying to make sense
of what's been going on and in doubt in
terms of you know one of the things
Carlos is describing is a kind of non
centering towards Hollywood like the
filmmakers in Latin America are looking
at all others of a diversity of systems
and the diversity of strategies and so
on as navigating around Hollywood and
finding success to do it even folks like
cuarón incredibly right so within the
world of festivals and distribution are
is that also occurring outside of this
kind of marquee we all know like if
you're for whatever reason to get your
movie into con or Sundance you're gonna
have an international community looking
at it for a moment in time our within
Latin America is there other kind of
systems for getting films outside
stepping around those marquee festivals
or is there Mithen part of the strategy
or has it been more produce in these
side side bar systems alternate systems
and then go through the front door in
terms of the marquee festival well I
think one of the ironic things maybe
about speaking specifically about Latin
American cinema and I'm gonna refer to
Mexico because that's the case I know
the best is that oftentimes
international film festivals open the
domestic market for them as well and I
think Carlos will agree with me right
that when a film is recognized has this
kind of imprimatur of the critics and
the buzz in festivals then it can be
shown on multiple domestic screens
because this is I spent a long hot
summer in Mexico City in which the only
thing I could see at a regular movie
theater except for the cineteca was
Batman Returns I feel like I feel like
there was showing on multiple screens in
every theater etc and that is still the
case that many Latin American kind of
commercial exhibition venues show
American films this is not just
case in Latinamerica its case and lots
of other countries as well but and but
you don't have a vision of going with a
friend to see a Mexican movie and we
said oh and she said oh I'm almost I
said about three you know so we're gonna
give ego be good citizens it's probably
not gonna be very good etc and I think
that really has changed in the last
twenty years definitely and I think but
I think that there is this irony and
this started with when well right at
most what we thought was the critics
hated it was horrible it went a prize
they were like oh he's our favorite guy
we love him and that movie so incredible
but you know so I think that there's a
bit of an irony there in the sometimes
local venues although there you know
there are micro cinemas I mean if we're
gonna study the kind of ecology of
exhibition there are places and you know
Latin America has a very robust film
culture comprised of scenic loops right
which are could be anything from like
the Faculty of Psychiatry at a
university that have a monthly cinema
show screening to micro cinemas to local
institutions like this in Ithaca that
dedicate a great deal of their
programming to films that are maybe
produced in these alternate kind of
paths etc I think that that that still
is very vibrant today so those are other
places where these films can find an
audience and I was really happy and
you're in your in your comments that you
mentioned the challenge is within these
countries obviously the Carlos's point
these are all giant countries and
they're not I mean there are countries
of various sizes but some of them are
massive countries in Latin America and
to kind of generalize about them really
erases a lot of history within those
countries and so I was really happy that
you brought up the ongoing struggle to
have an indigenous presence in Mexican
cinema
you know my there was an announcement in
variety I think five years ago that kind
of not guy Allen Diego's company was
going to produce the first indigenous
written and directed feature film in
Mexican history and I know the filmmaker
and the film has still not been produced
which is incredible in 2017 there still
hasn't been an indigenous helmed feature
film in met within Mexico a country that
has vast indigenous populations to this
day so so could you talk a little bit
about like what despite the fact that
there is a renaissance what are some of
the challenges within within inherent to
this project and yeah I mean I think
it's not only Mexico I mean
Lucrecia Martel talks about who is from
the north you know what western part of
argentina salta you know and she talks
about like kind of the dirt all this
rich you know diversity in terms of
indigenous groups but also kind of the
dearth in the country of recognizing you
know the importance of you know these
voices you know in film and in in you
know in you know culture in general and
in Mexico too and I think you know
there's I mean all of these various
groups of indigenous people in Mexico
like I have a student of mine who is
studying filmmakers and Oaxaca but you
know it's not what well haka is a state
right but she's looking at Zapotec and
mistake filmmakers and they have their
own collectives you know so they're not
part of you know like the national film
schools or not in you know the you know
in the kind of national industries but
they're really kind of working at the
local level where there's kind of
community support so in terms of kind of
these micro spaces
you know there's micro spaces you know
all over Latin America you have all of
these different indigenous and a frozen
groups as well you know we hardly talked
about we talked about the indigenous in
Latin America but we don't talk about
you know the afro-descendant groups who
are also you know you know in
many countries in Latin America I mean
we think about the mostly in Brazil but
here in Colombia there and you know I
hear the other in Chile there in all
these other places so I think that you
know there is a kind of a renaissance in
terms of that work but there's not
necessarily been the funding structures
to get this work in you know kind of
broader in kind of the broader screen or
you know kind of in international venues
and so forth so I think you know people
that are doing the kind of research or
giving doing the kind of exposure or
really you know well people are
beginning to focus on the kind of you
know independent works that are that are
going on and so that's why I do agree
that the the concept of Latin American
cinema is really kind of problematic
because it's sort of homogenizes this
incredible kind of diversity you're
really talking about you know twenty
countries and within those countries
more kind more nations you know that are
comprised of indigenous and you know
after descendant and even Asian you know
Latino as well you know so and may he's
going in Bedouin in other places you
know and so with that I guess we I was
speaking with Lourdes before this panel
and we were talking about the
Renaissance in in in Latin American film
and then talking about the kind of
counterpoint in terms of what's
happening here you know I have I have a
daughter and I think statistically and
I'm not saying this to be sarcastic or
glib but actually thinks statistically
the odds of her becoming a filmmaker in
today's marketplace and getting a film
as a young latina to get a film in a
theater are actually lower than her
being hit by lightning there's literally
the out of 50 million us Latinos 50
million of us here 5-0 million at least
I believe there was less than that the
practice there were three u.s. Latino
film productions last year that made it
to a theater I think I'd be over
counting I don't is literally I think
Rosellini was saying a studies said
there was zero yeah
at USC on represented under
representation of racial and women and
racial groups within nine hundred
popular films said did not I mean I read
the study and there was like two Asian
directors and the rest were white male
and there was quantified
african-american and then the rest were
white male and that's quantifying studio
films so it's in terms of what are we
looking at there's obviously a lot of
visual production from our communities
but in terms of getting through the kind
of studio system or getting a movie that
hits the theater
these numbers are you count them on one
hand in terms of out of 50 million
people in this country those have gotten
the shot to get into a movie theaters an
incredible quandary you know that that
we'd have a better chance of being hit
by lightning than making a movie but
Lourdes was saying if it's a Renaissance
in Latin America there's a retro sense
here in the US and I thought that word
I'm going to take it with me because I
think it's a I think it's aware so we're
going through a retro science um and how
do we end it you know is there anything
we can learn and I would say just in to
end on a kind of hopeful note just kind
of imagining if there was a sympathetic
administration that said what do you
want in the federal from a federal
government today to resolve this crisis
because we value the voices of our
Latino citizens and we want to know
their stories if there was that what
would it be that would what would help
or if the studio said and we want to
address this what would it be
because whatever we've been trying for
the past several decades because this
isn't a new issue it's an old issue a
lot of people in this room been talking
about it for decades I'm one of them and
it's not getting better it's getting
worse so in the spirit of not being
crazy people want to do the same thing
over and over again to get a different
result what could we do differently what
what isn't being done just ideas I think
what I mean Carlos mentioned it and I
think Lucretia Mott fell in her
interview as well talked about it it was
when you know Argentinian crisis
happened I mean people went
it took indeed co-productions and I
think that you know that's one
possibility of doing co-productions and
I'm not talking about I'm talking about
with other countries you know
co-productions you know between you know
Spain and you know us Latinos or between
you know us Latinos and Mexico or
between you know whatever industries in
in Latin America you know have that
availability and so I think that I mean
that's one option
you one thing that you said this has
been going on historically for a long
time I mean this has been going on you
know since since the 60s or even before
and I think that you know we've tried
boycotts we've tried all kinds of things
we've tried you know petitioning the
industry and so we might have to go you
know outside and do transnational
transit you know kind of local
productions that's one possibility
I also have to say or we have we also
have to set the platform because I do
because there's also film makers out
there I'm just thinking right now in the
cabinet like me shelf Stevenson with her
documentary American promise she's
Haitian Panamanian Canadian American you
know that's a whole thing you know a lot
of you know when you can call yourself
Latino it's a lot of majors but like
she's she's she has been able to make a
career in the nonfiction realm so
there's people there but we have to also
kind of make a census and really
connected connect the dots because
there's more dots to be connected than
we think in this country as well and
secondly you know open up how can we
learn in this country what's happened in
other parts of Latin America that again
they have tradition like a Costa Rica or
what them are are good examples how
they've they managed to foster a new
generation of filmmakers that can
continue to make films and that's key
how how do we give the possibility
filmmakers to have a film career and I
think that's key filmmakers to make one
two three four films the continuing
independently to what happens to those
films I mean of course that's important
but I think the keeper first is to allow
to have you should you should be filming
tomorrow fanatics for example I'm kind
of feeling cynical these days so it's
hard for me to enter into your world of
fantasy although I will say that from
looking at these interviews it was clear
that there were programs that were
supported that really made work like a
North Day like these really important
she connects films that the next films
possible in the 80s and the 90s and that
seems to have fallen out of fashion
somewhat so if we were asking for
programmatic
funding you know I think that would be
because filmmaking is an expensive
endeavor regardless of whether you're
making nonfiction films or you know and
collectives that pull their resources
maybe that's another this is you know
Rosalinda is talking about transnational
collaboration but maybe there's kind of
collective resource pooling that could
also be really interesting man I really
want to share my ideas but it's but one
thing I would say just real quick is
that just to add a splash of paint on
the board is that you know there is a
history to doing this kind of thing in
this country itvs maybe people in the
room know what itvs is the independent
television service based in San
Francisco a budget of oh I think about
fifteen million dollars a year they
mostly support documentary where did it
come from it's public money it's
government money that supports it
it came from independent filmmakers
lobbying it was a three three guys named
what were their names
no the the guy that currents California
newsreel anyways I think they were all
named Scott it was some like this but
all three of them had the same name they
were all the same name they moved to
they were representing the association
of independent video and film makers and
which was an organization of filmmakers
and they went to DC and they lobbied and
they said we need to have funding to
create educational independent films and
they got a little tiny line-item the 15
million dollars today it's one of the
best games in town for documentary
filmmakers but we forget that it came
from filmmakers saying we can change
things and we have a crisis right now in
this country where buildings are being
destroyed and falling down in Mexico
City
Puerto Rico is being destroyed and our
politicians want to build a wall
[ __ ] with no roof you know just a wall
there's a deep sickness in this country
in my opinion part of it is the lack of
our stories being told it's a backdrop
that allows that kind of sickness to
grow we need our stories to be told and
if we can't imagine a way to change this
situation if we can even say it if we
can imagine it it's not going to change
our numbers are not going to change it
50 million people is enough to deserve
the change we can't reproduce our way
out of this one so with that I would
invite the rest of the panelists back
onto the stage Catherine Kerry Jose come
on come on up and let's face the public
thank you
[Applause]
five million fifty-five million Latinos
so and one of them is mine so but maybe
maybe when we get to sixty we get to
make films
okay so hope folks are out there
thinking about questions or comments and
believe we've got a microphone at the
front of each aisle and so please step
right up step right up and good
afternoon
first of all again I want to thank the
Academy I want to thank all the
panelists my friend Jimmy Alex I don't
know you but hello I'm Minerva I'm
coming with this comment from a very
pissed-off very pissed off feeling as a
woman as a woman in the industry as a
woman of color or Ocella in this comment
of us being erased completely I mean and
it's not just you know Latinas it's
African Americans it's you know I mean
more white women are represented but I
really want to get to the root of the
frickin problem why are we erased as
women older women and also you know I
include our fellow Latino filmmakers we
are erased it's like who the hell gave
you birth who the hell raised you and
then why do you go and make your film
with 20 men and one woman so I want to
know from filmmakers why why do you do
this why do you erase your mothers your
sisters your daughters I want to know
and how the F do we frickin finally
break that well I I would say you know
again women are obviously a majority and
always have been so when we talk about
getting minorities into film it's such a
women or majority and have been
represented I think in numbers around 5%
6% within the ranks of studio directors
and so again this is not a question
about like these are new communities
that are trying to work their way into a
system the majority majority's like
women have been excluded historically to
this day and so there's something very
grave going on that numbers and
demographics aren't going to change
looks like Katherine might have some
ideas about what will change it
well I actually think that's where Latin
America can be very instructive because
if you look at women's participation in
Latin American film industries it's been
there for a long time and in fact they
have sort of jump-started a lot of new
waves of filmmaking right the whole hit
Amada in Brazil in the 90s there were a
lot of women filmmakers so I think
there's a different sense of how to
build right collaboration in in a
filmmaking project than there is here
and I think maybe Rosalinda wants to
follow from this but I just wanted to
say that this is one of the areas where
Latin America has a lot to teach and one
just think one thing to put on the table
just in terms of when we talk about
these numbers maybe if there it is worth
its distinguishing between documentary
and fiction because in this country I
know that women I think over index and
the production of Elementary's and then
are nearly absent in the production of
sort of studio feature film well again
documentaries the budgets are lower
there was this almost a stealth takeover
but because when nobody cares I want to
have the only you know the only little
stat I like to throw in is from 1925 but
up until 1925 half of all films were
written by women ie when people didn't
care about the business women were
thriving color though that's your
question though in particular and are
you talking about in in studio films or
just in film in general in general yeah
I mean I'm not so sure I mean they're
women the women in the oral history
project and also other you know women
filmmakers that you know I've researched
you know they're not necessarily that
celebratory I mean Mariano vato talks
about you know the fact that you know
her film scene the hard way yeah which
is a road film about women you know like
plate like for a week
and how she was attacked when she made
the film done sawn by the Mexican male
critics you know and because you know
for the for the topic of the film and
you know so I'm not necessarily you know
that's celebratory about you know
women's participation I think there are
many women filmmakers in Latin America
but I also think that there's a dearth
and there has been a marginalization as
well and in this country as well in the
various in that Chicano film oven I mean
I wrote about that
you know and there was a modern
exclusionary practices of women from the
Chicano film movement as well many of
the filmmakers that you know we will see
you or you know very prominent
filmmakers but there weren't inclusive
of of women filmmakers so there is there
has been a problem for for a very long
time and I'm not sure the solution is of
course you know holding accountability
in holding these filmmakers accountable
for that those exclusionary practices
you know yeah and I would just name
those exclusionary practices sexism yeah
I hate let's call it what it is and I
would say you know although women were
writers carry they're really not that
many well-known female directors but my
colleague Mark Garrett Cooper has this
really interesting book about it's
called Universal women and it's about
this moment in the teens when there were
a handful of not just women directors
but like kind of really famous and
powerful women directors like Louis
Weber who had complete creative control
who could who could Bank a film etc and
the argument that he makes in this book
and this is getting around to how do we
change this is that this had to do with
an institution so institutions have
ideas about gender right and part of his
thesis in the book is that at a certain
point the job the labor of directing
became a job that was a job for men
whereas at the moment when these women
were really active and receiving a lot
of support from the studios that job was
not exactly genderless but it was more
flexible right so in some ways it's
about changing the culture right in
which women are not seen as kind of
either relegated to certain kinds of
work in the industry which I know
happens because I talk to my students
and I know that they get and have pushed
into very particular career paths that
where people hire like editors they hire
a lot in women etc but also changing the
kind of norms of gender in an in an
institution you can think of filmmaking
kind of writ large as an institution
with lots of sub institutions in it but
really changing ideas about how that and
that I think is a process of Education
because once people can see and that's
not an easy answer I'm gonna turn a punt
on that question but once people see
that as systemic and not coincidental
then and I think this accountability and
a piece is yeah I also think
collaboration the idea the spirit of
collaboration is very important and I
think that's what the women who were
working in Mexico and Colombia in the
80s had in mind right that you sort of
can collectively produce works that you
have a sort of flexible definition of
what directing means of what
cinematography means of what writing
means and I think you know we see this
to be easier in the case of documentary
it's harder in the case of fiction where
the notion of authorship sort of begins
to kick in but I think collaboration is
very important and wonderful and I'm so
sorry if it's okay maybe we weave some
of this into the the remaining
conversations we don't I'm so sorry but
one final thing is like Maria Novella
talks about the fact that she left the
union in Mexico this is The Syndicate Oh
because a woman couldn't touch a camera
and she wanted to have a cinematographer
who was a woman so she just form
collectives you know so I mean this is
like you know one thing I was gonna say
as I know this isn't a formally a panel
about advocacy and it's a panel about
Latin America and Los Angeles but
obviously when we started to look at
this side of that on this side of the
looking glass we have to go into this
terrain because unfortunately we can't
have a robust conversation about the the
myriad of lucky u.s. Latino cinematic
production even though that being said
there certainly is and tonight on the
Latinas panel we're going to hear from
some dynamic and and and groundbreaking
and vicious like you know film they're
going to say it because they're my
friends looking forward to hearing from
them tonight somebody used the
expression Latin X films is that a new
cultural category can you tell us a
little bit about that
okay well Spanish is gendered right it's
a language I mean when we speak about
nouns and so when you refer to male
directors and Latino directors or women
directors to be latina directors and so
this was an idea of sort of not creating
that kind of gender boundary sort of
from the get-go but rather to allow for
some kind of flexibility there so the X
means to be determined or however one
wishes to define it and I think that
that then got extended to Chicano and
Chicana okay hi good afternoon I'm a
writer-director currently attending film
school I'll be graduating very soon and
I was hearing finally the word I was
looking for was collaboration because
filmmaking is a collaborative
environment but what I keep hearing is
how you're looking to possibly and
recommend co-productions with us-based
Chicano or let you know filmmakers who
go to another
country into collaborations but I
haven't heard anything about possibly
collaborating with our african-american
brothers and sisters and the some of the
production companies for example Ava
Duvernay with her show Queen sugar she's
hired all women directors and I believe
two of them were Latinas this last
season not only that but one of the less
celebrated and I believe totally snubbed
episodes within Queen sugar actually had
a segment with farm workers out in the
south and was completely done
bilingually and in Spanish and was
better done than some of the Latino
shows on TV so going back to that we
keep saying let's go back to Latin
America let's go back to Spain let's
collaborate let's do ba ba ba ba ba but
we have african-american brothers and
sisters and especially when we live in
LA and if we were from LA we don't live
in a silo especially if we're not from
East LA like I'm not so I grew up around
people that were of different
nationalities so it's more realistic for
me to say I'm gonna collaborate with
another person of color then saying I'm
gonna collaborate with another Latino
great well is anyone what I love to me
that's a guide in my own personal life
and I find it inspiring and if anyone
wants to talk about that or also I think
it's also looming a little bit has there
been much of a practice given this
Renaissance and these kind of titans of
cinema coming out of Latin America of
them entering this you u.s. Latino space
and offering opportunity mentorship
solidarity is that does that exchange
exists much I honestly don't I am asking
because I don't know there's a generally
generation of filmmakers I'm thinking
Rodrigo Reyes he he's based well if you
finally moved to him of to outline
recently but he was based in in Modesto
I believe and he was working as a
translator in the court
he's found he's found some funds to make
his films in Mexico actually cuz it's
originally tried here but hearing was
there getting funding so he met a
producer in Mexico and they found a way
to produce his work and now he's going
through his third filming he's so I
think we still sing more younger
generation kind of opening those doors
we need more of that and and I know it's
working as you know as those connectors
but I also I agree I mean and again is
there's no again there's no really one
formula we need to open up to allow
different kinds of productions to
coexist I think that's also key I think
mentoring is essential I mean finding a
mentor I think the industry is really
opened to you know to keep their time
and talk to students and they're very
helpful I mean I'm a mentor in any stage
of life is very important I just want to
think I said with the comment that the
woman made was just so important and I
think we do need to reach out to other
communities of color and I think that's
really a really a brilliant idea and I
think I'm glad that she raised it and
it's important for filmmakers to do that
so I wanted to applaud her yeah thank
you for that comment can I just briefly
say that I think there are some
historical models for just the kind of
collaboration that between communities
of color
for example William Greaves who's best
known as an experimental documentarian
and a master of the kind of
african-american documentary film also
made this series of films for the EEOC
in the early 1970s in which he
collaborated with Jose Garcia was a
Puerto Rican filmmaker from New York and
they worked together on these films that
were about they were about their
sponsored films so they have kind of
educational purpose and stuff but I
think it's beneficial for us to be
mindful of precedence right for just
precisely the kind of collaboration that
you're talking about and that happened
because they were working in the same
kind of milieu in New York both Jose
Garcia and William Greaves and so they
knew each other and so bill Greaves said
hey I
need you to help me write for this film
and then he had another Porter we can do
the sound for the film and the film
stars stars Anthony Quinn and Rita
Moreno but but I think it's really
interesting to think back historically
on how that that kind of collaborative
collaboration is produced right in what
kind of institutions and contexts and
one of the filmmakers I think you might
be referring to I would order Guerrero
who she is that she kind of filmmaker
who worked with Ava Duvernay his company
on Queen sugar embodying that kind of
solidarity and that kind of possibility
you know she'll be here tonight so it's
she's a badass okay thank you
oh yeah how are you my name is Jose I'm
Chinese and I'm from Venezuela I just
wanna say thank you for coming here
sharing experiences I didn't think I
could be an actor back in Venezuela and
after coming here for college I think
yeah it can be it can happen so I just
wanna ask you maybe one of you each one
can give me just maybe a suggestion for
all the John people are here in America
what they can do to help me that change
in the Latino or Asian or anything to
push the the film industry like to make
that change so what's like that maybe
sharing that article on Facebook or
maybe that trailer that your friend from
Chile made here in u.s. so maybe just
that little suggestions you may have for
young people well it sounds like you
have some ideas already so those are
good to share I'm not sure we have time
for everybody but anybody have a
something to offer if you want something
be persistent be persistent
try to transform certain situations into
opportunities such as internships right
if you were studying film you're
studying acting sometimes we were able
to intern and that can lead to something
else and I think I know one of the oral
histories reveals how important that was
to an actor's career and so even if you
are not officially part of something any
kind of participation really helps and
then to take that as a platform to move
forward and watch films they film their
films of the filmmakers should be basic
curricula so start from there also I
think it's important also from there
from from the past filmmakers I think
watching films is very important ok I
just wanted to add to that I know you're
not asking me but I'm I'm actually a
trailer editor for Universal which I
which I never thought I would come out
to LA to become and one of the things
that I would say is also look for the
gaps where there's industries and
positions where there's nobody like you
because your perspective will totally be
appreciated well God willing but I also
just wanted to comment Rosalinda as
somebody who's kind of in the belly of
the beast in the studio I completely
agree with you saying that even the
concept of Latin American film is kind
of a reductionist thing because I know
whenever I have to cut a Hispanic spot
my question is is okay so we're doing a
spot for Miami and Chicago and LA are
are you mad so so yeah I just wanted to
say I appreciate you saying that because
I'm in marketing and I kind of don't
understand it and I really wish my
industry would catch up and just kind of
as you know as as a you know a Chicano
one of the things that I've you know
been looking at is you know all of my
heroes in the 80s and the 90s you know
the Cheech is the Louise the Robert
Rodriguezes
and just sing I mean roughly in the arts
you know how a lot of that disappeared I
mean even la stories you know real women
have curves you know was a you know a
latin-american national lowriders you
know Latin American national and you
know thank God for the Aurora's thank
God for you Alex my sleep dealers dope
yeah but but you know my question is you
know what happened from the age of El
Mariachi to now when you know you can
have a little cute indie Sundance movie
and get a hundred fifty million dollar
franchise movie you know unless your
last name ends in a Z so I wanted to you
know kind of get some of your
perspectives on that thank you so much
man thank you for that does anyone have
any ideas in terms of what change does
is that analysis like from a sort of
scholarly point of view right that there
was maybe more production in the 90s
with in the u.s. Latino world than there
is today is is that a is that new
numerically I cared for folks that are
in this within the industry yeah I think
so and I think a lot of it has to do
with the social movements but I don't I
think we might see a shift in that
because I think with this president and
with the cutbacks in public funding that
you know he and his administration are
proposing with the kind of white
supremacy that we see that's just become
unleashed in this country I think we're
gonna see the beginning of social
movements and perhaps that will be a
change as well an opening I think this
is a good opening I think we you know we
need to go further than I'm talking
about this la la prajak is fantastic you
know but I think we need to move further
than that and I think you're gonna begin
to see a lot more you know coalitional
work and a lot more pressure on on
institutional racism in this country and
it includes the studios as well so we
can't you know think about that there
emp'd from what's happening in the pin
the broader context so I'm hoping that
that will push it in another direction I
want to hear from more folks from the
public I would just say you know there's
another panel maybe in some other
reality where we could talk from where I
would share my story with with maybe
some my colleagues who made a first film
and got to Sundance and won awards and
it's myself I would order Cruz on
Haley's there is a kind of I would call
us almost a lost generation man I mean
we got we did to get a shot and it's
been 10 years for me I haven't made the
second film I'm about to I'm about to
it's Annie was a story there and it's
not me it's a story it's a story of a
generation yeah and we could parse that
another time but I guess to my friend
here hello I am Scott I'm a college
professor I was so excited about this
event
I brought my entire freshman class raise
your hands raise your hands if there's a
question so I have in the idea I was
waiting I counted I have eight men and
eight women I have all different races
represented these guys are gonna inherit
this industry what would you like to say
to these people who soon are gonna take
over this whole thing thank you charge
of all of this but I'd like this what
would you like to say emerging you know
five and ten years from now continue
making more love and you know keep keep
focus on what the things that you need
to express with your creativity share
your culture you know I think also we is
trying to be idealistic again we need to
feature better worlds that we have and
that's I think the problem that we
there's no alternative right now so it's
really on year to really imagine any
possible future worlds and you know we
need a lot of activism but I think we
also need a lot of would go back to the
idealism of the 60s and we need to think
about better features
better worlds that we can have no whites
freedom from our different cultures from
other parts of the world see ludus poor
theosis interview and I think she Maria
Navarro also talked about the importance
of telling your story and I've being
persistent in telling your story we need
to hear those stories yeah oh and the
other thing I would say is that
technology is not just magic
that there are a lot of different
approaches and I think that some of the
strengths of the cinema that is
represented in the series is that people
also thought of artisanal ways to make
films and so your engagement with that
technology is very important too you
know you can make it say work in certain
ways that maybe other people haven't so
try to explore those ways as well I
remember technology is it's just a tool
what a mallet is what's in your mind
because that's where the ideas come from
thank you very much you know I would
just say if if for the folks that are
within the Latino sphere if you're
looking for Latino films here you're not
seeing them and you feel depressed look
at other art forms look at our
literature look at theater in this
century some of the greatest works of
literature the brief wondrous life of
Oscar Wow by Junot Diaz Hamilton by
lin-manuel Miranda are the luminous
dominant works in those mediums and we
can absolutely have a cinema that hits
at that level there's no reason we can't
so let's say like take in a lot of
artwork made by people who you who are
lives what you've lived because it's out
there in other forms it's not with us
yet in the cinema but it can be thank
you so much we have time for one more
question
oh boy can we just let everyone in the
public say their thing and then maybe
we'll talk about it informally outside
is that okay we just run the questions
with no answers and we'll speak outside
how about this let's run the questions
and then just get a splash of quick
answers but let's hear from everybody
there's some young folks I want to hear
what they have to say um so I just I
know that there's been a lot of press
about the success of Latin America like
telenovelas and television and I know
that you're all like focus on cinema so
you might not know but I'm wondering if
there's some like collaboration that
could happen between the cinema in the
television industry and whether that
could be a road to success and sort of
as a second part to that question I know
that some of the success has come from
selling of formats so there's been like
a telenovela that's been successful and
then that's sold as a format and then
it's reproduced like in the United
States or elsewhere but maybe not with
the same directors or actresses or
actors or in a circle western style and
I'm wondering if that is seen
beneficially as like giving bringing
money into the system or whether that's
seen as harmful or hurtful I didn't know
what selling a format was until about
three months ago I thought it's a thank
you for the question we'll get at it and
so really quickly I'm going at you from
like a writer's perspective since you
guys are filmmakers and scholars and
consumers of film and media what are
some motifs or some character arcs or
something and Latinos stories that kind
of stand out and stuff that needs to be
not recreated but may be hit again or
something that can help these Latino
stories kind of come back into like the
mainstream so the question of formats
and work from Latin America kind of
reproduced here I mean if I'm not
mistaken Jane the Virgin is one such
case Ugly Betty it's okay so and so
maybe just I suppose does anyone want to
comment on yeah what that does is
culturally and within the industry well
actually I'm a little bit skeptical of
that because I think basically you're
buying a format and what that is what
kind of substance that has will change
in in a different context ugly Betty's
character and what she was able to
achieve definitely changed in
u.s. context is compared to the Mexican
and Colombian context on what I think is
interesting is a question of TV and film
one of the things that comes out in the
oral histories is that a lot of
filmmakers got their first opportunity
in television some publicly-funded
you know such as American Playhouse
others directing episodes and so I think
that is it to be open to that you know
as a possibility and to try to learn
from that I think is really important I
think formats are just an easy way to
just keep regenerating you know
breathing energy into into an industry I
think it's much more important in terms
of cat what how you cast a program where
the setting is whether there's a sense
of place in the program and and how you
deal with language and that sort of
thing thank you and Bruce a Linda the
final thing quickly I had a wonderful
conversation without aura Guerrero and
she said some of the most exciting
things for Latinas and Latinos is
happening in television you know so I
think we shouldn't that the question is
important but it's also important in
this country as well you know and and
anyone want to touch this question of
themes kind of and maybe to give it a
different spin in terms of theme are
there themes that you've seen in latinum
in Latin American production that have
been sort of like gateways or places
that filmmakers have started off the the
I think Catherine you mentioned the B
movies and Latin America to people get
in starting off with a kind of
gangbanger type of things or stove's the
stories about narco that I'm not sure
what a Mike I'm sure is there like a
place that people start off working
because of like expediency is in the
market that then become a building block
where you can go on and have a bigger
and richer career are there somatic sort
of spaces of opportunity that we should
be thinking about I'm skeptical of that
but but basically no no but that is a
good question I mean actually you know
it's it's a phase the narco is a phase
in in B production and there was a whole
other there are other themes and B
production
and one of them was um female hair
heroism mmm-hmm you know and the ability
to seek justice you know and and to be
doing it across the border so I think
it's kind of interesting that there are
different visions you know that have
been breathed in to be filmmaking and
there's much more than meets the eye and
of course Lane damn buddy yeah you know
who made a lot of films in the 80s she's
talking more films than anybody you know
mostly B movies a lot shown on
television on television
these were comedy comedies you know
talking about indigeneity and Mexican
culture and also how and digit people
are seen by North Americans so yeah I
think I think one I think it's probably
more possible in television than today
than in B movies I think you kind of get
isolated into B movies one final comment
from anybody else we all set
good okay well at the beginning of a
conversation an urgent conversation in
an urgent time thank you it's not I
think it's my first time saying I want
to thank the Academy I hope it's not
much I hope it's not my last but anyways
I do sincerely want to thank the Academy
and PS T for for opening this space and
letting us get together and start this
conversation will continue it for the
rest of the day thank you before
everybody leaves I just want to say
thank you to Alex and to all our
panelists for being here today I also
want to say you've heard about the oral
histories they're all streamable online
you can go to Oscars org and find them
on the PST part of the website there are
13 I believe or 12 right now there will
be another 13 coming so check back
because we're adding to them this is a
continuum it will not be the end it is
the seed that has been planted and is
sprouting many other fruits and thank
you Rosalinda for helping part of the UC
Santa Cruz collection come
to the academy library where it's
accessible to future researchers one
other piece that has been added to the
collections and to the gift that is pstl
ala and filmmakers everywhere make sure
that things from your history your
collection your BIOS are in our library
we want to be inclusive but sometimes if
you've got that extra poster or that
extra film print or whatever bring it to
our eye carve our library and those of
you who are students here and teachers
like Scott come to see these films and
if you don't have the money you call me
up and you will get in free because we
want you here to see these films that
this is not this is not a movie theater
to make money this is a movie theater to
plant seeds so please students come we
want you here the teachers bring your
students parents bring your children
thank you all Thank You Lourdes talk
about sees the mother earth here
planting and Thank You Ellen for
overseeing this today as well as a major
huge chunk of all this initiative thank
you the staff the Academy Dawn Mori
thank you and have a safe trip come back
at seven o'clock